Jake:好开始了
Jake: Okay, let's start.
Tasha: 好开始了
Tasha: Okay, let's start.
Jake:来看一眼
Jake: Let's take a look.
Katrina: 然后在想什么时候回去
Katrina: And then think about when to go back.
Tasha: 看了
Tasha: Seen it.
Jake:看了好
Jake: Seen it, good.
Jake:VR我们也一起看一下
Jake: Let's check out the VR together too.
Katrina: 要是要是失败了马上回去
Katrina: If we fail, we'll go back right away.
Jake:好的好看我
Jake: Alright, look at me.
Lucia: 我傻了
Lucia: I'm so dumbfounded.
Jake:但我看到的是反的啊
Jake: But what I see is reversed.
Jake:好我现在才知道好的
Jake: Okay, now I know, alright.
Tasha: 好了吗好
Tasha: Done? Okay.
Jake:好可以
Jake: Okay, it's good.
Tasha: 继续
Tasha: Continue.
Jake:呃在这
Jake: Uh, over here.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:有点烘焙天赋在身上吧
Jake: You have some baking talent, right?
Tasha: 有点烘焙天赋在身上的哈哈
Tasha: You have some baking talent, hahaha.
Jake:啊这么回事
Jake: Ah, that's how it is.
Jake:多少 0.5%技能点点吧
Jake: How much? 0.5% skill points?
Tasha: 技能点点满
Tasha: Max out the skill points.
Jake:0.3%不能再多了
Jake: 0.3%, can't give you more.
Jake:好好好可以
Jake: Alright, alright, good.
Tasha: 切了吗哦对吧
Tasha: Did you cut it? Oh right.
Jake:好我来骑
Jake: Okay, I'll ride.
Lucia: 刀还用这个刀吗
Lucia: Should I still use this knife?
Tasha: 你不切了吗
Tasha: Aren't you going to cut it?
Jake:啊我要骑
Jake: Ah, I need to ride.
Tasha: 啊你好忙呀哈哈哈
Tasha: Ah, you're so busy, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈好好好你来骑
Jake: Hahaha, alright, alright, you ride.
Lucia: 啊那我来挤哈哈哈
Lucia: Ah, then I'll squeeze, hahaha.
Tasha: 那我来切
Tasha: Then I'll cut.
Jake:那我干嘛
Jake: Then what do I do?
Lucia: 短暂的换一下任务
Lucia: Let's switch tasks for a bit.
不可能的
Not possible.
怎么不可能
How is it not possible?
Jake:那我给你们加油
Jake: Then I'll cheer you on.
Lucia: 这个这个放在这
Lucia: Put this here.
从来没有想过表白成功的可能性
Never thought about the possibility of confessing successfully.
Lucia: 这案板应该可以直接用
Lucia: This chopping board should be usable directly.
Tasha: 你们一人切一半吧
Tasha: You guys each cut half.
Lucia: 一人可啊
Lucia: Each one can, yeah.
Tasha: 啊你们一人挤一半吧
Tasha: Oh, you each squeeze half.
Lucia: 嗯救救
Jake:帮我救救4吧
Jake: Help me save number 4.
Tasha: 救
Tasha: Save.
Jake:经济学大师
Jake: Economics master.
Tasha: 救4是什么意思哦
Tasha: What does it mean to save 4?
Lucia: 就是吗你说的是哦 4 嗯嗯
Lucia: Is that what you mean? 4, hmm.
Tasha: 哦 救救4号
Lucia: 经济学还是有些解决不了的问题
Lucia: Economics still has some unsolvable problems.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia: 你知道吗哈哈
Lucia: You know, haha.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Jake:4号真的好惨
Jake: Number 4 is really miserable.
Lucia: 给他多放点奶油吧
Lucia: Give him more cream.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 咱给他放一个大的草莓或者
Lucia: Let's give him a big strawberry or something.
我靠你别挑拨离间
Damn, don't sow discord.
Tasha: 我这个人还是很公平的
Tasha: I am actually quite fair.
Tasha: 没有大葱哎
Tasha: There's no green onion.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
你是最大的
You are the biggest.
Jake:市场不允许
Jake: The market doesn't allow it.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Tasha: 哇哇
Tasha: Wow, wow.
Jake:哇你这贴的好好看
Jake: Wow, you placed it so nicely.
Lucia: 哇好看
Lucia: Wow, it looks great.
Lucia: 这个草莓看着就让人觉得食欲大开
Lucia: This strawberry looks really appetizing.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 大家都很会夸
Tasha: Everyone is so good at praising.
Lucia: 这应该挤多点挤少点就像那天那样挤
Lucia: Should we squeeze more or less, like that day?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Jake:你那个艺术蛋糕
Jake: Your artistic cake.
Tasha: 你那个艺术蛋糕很艺术
Tasha: Your artistic cake is really artistic.
Tasha: 那天起的哈哈
Tasha: That day was amazing, haha.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Jake:哈哈哈这个我觉得像在化鸟巢
Jake: Hahaha, I think this looks like building a bird's nest.
Lucia: 哈哈你看我每次都把它踢不断好怪哦
Lucia: Haha, look, I always fail to kick it down, it's so weird.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:这回弄水立方
Jake: This time, let's make a Water Cube.
Lucia: 但是他中间就会逐渐那个啥
Lucia: But it will gradually become, you know...
Jake:哦你还得给他封个顶
Jake: Oh, you have to seal the top.
Tasha: 空
Tasha: Empty.
Lucia: 对没事我会有草莓的
Lucia: Yeah, no worries, I'll add some strawberries.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 这就叫凯恩斯经济学
Lucia: This is called Keynesian economics.
Lucia: 就我们只看短期
Lucia: We only look at the short term.
Lucia: 长远的这些另说
Lucia: We'll talk about the long term later.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 我们这个恩格尔系数拉满了
Tasha: Our Engel coefficient is maxed out.
Lucia: 我们这个恩格尔系数拉满了
Lucia: Our Engel coefficient is maxed out.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 就是啊我们的预算都用在支撑
Lucia: Yeah, all our budget is used to support it.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 点缀哎可以先我把这一圈给画完
Lucia: Embellish it, okay, let me finish this circle first.
Lucia: 画都画了
Lucia: It's drawn.
Lucia: 给他封口吧
Lucia: Let's seal it.
Lucia: 哎呀断了
Lucia: Oops, it broke.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 那就将错就错了
Lucia: Just go with it then.
Lucia: 大家都是很豁达的人
Lucia: Everyone is very open-minded.
Tasha: 哇内外都在欢声笑语
Tasha: Wow, laughter inside and out.
Jake:哎发生什么了
Jake: Hey, what's happening?
Lucia: 哇内外都在欢声笑语哈哈
Lucia: Wow, laughter inside and out, haha.
Jake:哈哈来打听打听
Jake: Haha, let's find out.
Lucia: 外面进度怎么样了能吃吗
Lucia: How's the progress outside, can we eat?
Tasha: 外面进度怎么样了能吃吗
Tasha: How's the progress outside, can we eat?
Jake:发生什么事了
Jake: What's happening?
Tasha: 里面的进度已经快结束了
Tasha: The progress inside is almost done.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 你看每次都拉不断好生气
Lucia: Look, I always fail to tear it, so frustrating.
Jake:好嘞好嘞
Jake: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 微微你要挤一排吗
Lucia: Tasha, do you want to squeeze out a row?
Lucia: 还是还是怎么样你挤吧
Lucia: Or how about you squeeze it out?
Tasha: 啊都可以
Tasha: Ah, it's all fine.
Tasha: 你挤吧你们一人挤6个
Tasha: You squeeze it, each of you squeeze 6.
Jake:你们一人举六个
Jake: Each of you lift six.
Lucia: 好的谢谢老师
Lucia: Okay, thank you, teacher.
Tasha: 好谢谢老师啊
Tasha: Alright, thank you, teacher.
Jake:好我来去
Jake: Alright, I'm going.
Jake:我领肉去
Jake: I'm going to get the meat.
Jake:这盘子OK
Jake: This plate is OK.
Tasha: 我们不一起出去吃吗
Tasha: Aren't we going out to eat together?
Tasha: 挤完就出去吧
Tasha: Let's go out after squeezing.
Jake:哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Lucia: 没事让他先领吧
Lucia: It's fine, let him go first.
Lucia: 挤可能还要挤
Lucia: Squeezing may take a while.
Lucia: 挤完还得一小会
Lucia: It will still take a little while after squeezing.
Lucia: 然后咱就可以把这都端出去了
Lucia: Then we can take all of this out.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 耶
Lucia: Yay.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay.
Tasha: 哦这个记得不错谢谢
Tasha: Oh, you remembered this well, thanks.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Jake:我先把盘子送出去
Jake: I'll take the plates out first.
Lucia: 我感觉我们一会是可能还是会有多的
Lucia: I feel like we might still have more later.
Jake:我来送盘子来了
Jake: I'm taking the plates out.
Lucia: 然后再补
Lucia: Then we'll refill.
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Lucia: 我能直接吃咱的原材料吗哈哈哈
Lucia: Can I just eat our raw materials, hahaha.
Tasha: 好了你的6个已领完
Tasha: Alright, your 6 are done.
Tasha: 今日任务领取完毕
Tasha: Today's task is complete.
Tasha: 哈哈哈换下一位小朋友吧哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha, next kid, please, hahaha.
Lucia: 今日任务
Lucia: Today's task.
Lucia: 今日任务已完成
Lucia: Today's task is done.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh dear.
Jake:好看
Jake: Looks good.
Tasha: 下一个小朋友
Tasha: Next kid.
Tasha: 你多几点
Tasha: How many do you have?
Jake:我想想我怎么把它给填满
Jake: Let me think how to fill this up.
Jake:好谢谢
Jake: Alright, thanks.
Lucia: 留给下一位小朋友的
Lucia: For the next kid.
Jake:留给下一位小朋友的这个余额还用多
Jake: The balance for the next kid is still a lot.
Lucia: 这个这个余额还有很多哈哈
Lucia: This balance is still a lot, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:那我一开始得使劲的挥霍一番
Jake: Then I need to splurge a lot at the start.
Lucia: 哈哈你真是P人哈哈哈
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈你在
Lucia: Hahaha, you're...
Tasha: 哈哈哈不知道他急什么救命啊
Tasha: Hahaha, I don't know why he's in such a hurry, help!
Lucia: 你在蛋糕上做雕塑吗
Lucia: Are you making a sculpture on the cake?
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Tasha: 女人你在玩火哈
Tasha: Girl, you're playing with fire, huh?
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How about it?
Jake:哈哈哈可以可以特别好特别好
Jake: Hahaha, it's good, it's really good.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Lucia: 可以可以特别好
Lucia: Yeah, it's really good.
Tasha: 特别好
Tasha: Really good.
Lucia: 就是有种不知所云的美感
Lucia: It has this kind of inexplicable beauty.
Jake:就是有种不知所欲的那个
Jake: Yeah, it has that kind of inexplicable...
Tasha: 那个那个那个杜上的那个小便池
Tasha: Like that, that, that Duchamp's urinal.
Lucia: 有那个杜尚的那个
Lucia: It has that Duchamp's...
Jake:那个杜尚的那个
Jake: That Duchamp's...
Lucia: 哈哈小编池哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha, urinal, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈OK
Jake: Hahaha, OK.
Tasha: 对你知道吗
Tasha: Yeah, you know?
Tasha: 就是图上图上他是一个艺术家
Tasha: Duchamp, he's an artist.
Jake:OK我知道了
Jake: OK, I get it.
Tasha: 他把小便池作为一件艺术品
Tasha: He made the urinal an art piece.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Lucia: 对然后名字叫全
Lucia: Yeah, and it's called "Fountain."
Lucia: 哈哈我见过这个艺术品的实物
Lucia: Haha, I've seen this artwork in person.
Tasha: 哈哈我见过这个艺术品的实物哦
Tasha: Haha, I've seen this artwork in person, too.
Lucia: 我在伦敦的泰特美术馆里
Lucia: At the Tate Museum in London.
Lucia: 然后有一个小哥从旁边走过去
Lucia: And a guy walked by.
Lucia: 一个外国人
Lucia: A foreigner.
Lucia: 对然后他当时看了一眼这个
Lucia: Yeah, and he looked at it.
Lucia: 然后跟他旁身边一个女生
Lucia: And said to the girl next to him,
Lucia: 可能是他女票或者之类的
Lucia: Maybe his girlfriend or something,
Lucia: 说这是个坚持吧
Lucia: He said, "This is a masterpiece, right?"
Tasha: 哈哈对但他觉得他是一个艺术品
Tasha: Haha, yeah, but he thought it was an art piece.
Tasha: 对要不来一个
Tasha: Yeah, should we do one too?
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha, yeah.
Tasha: 啊哈哈
Tasha: Ah, haha.
Lucia: 别别别别
Lucia: No, no, no, no.
Lucia: 咱这是吃的
Lucia: We're eating this.
Lucia: 哈哈来一个这个
Lucia: Haha, let's get this one.
Jake:来一个艺术品
Jake: Let's get an art piece.
Tasha: 这个就这样子
Tasha: This one just like this.
Lucia: 就这样子是吗
Lucia: Just like this, right?
Jake:是这样子的吗好的
Jake: Is it like this? Alright.
Tasha: 是吗好的那我给他来个小点的水果
Tasha: Really? Alright, then I'll get a smaller fruit for him.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Alright.
Lucia: 那我给他来个小点的水
Lucia: Then I'll get a smaller water for him.
Jake:那得竖竖上去
Jake: It needs to go vertical.
Jake:对这样子啊
Jake: Yeah, like this.
Lucia: 这样子啊
Lucia: Like this?
Lucia: 你想拧歪还是拧歪
Lucia: Do you want to twist it or not?
Lucia: 这垫在后边他不用倒
Lucia: If you put this behind, it won't fall.
Lucia: 哇哇我知道了
Lucia: Wow, wow, I got it.
Lucia: 您肯定是想表达这样的想法
Lucia: You're definitely trying to express this idea.
Jake:猜你想搜
Jake: Guess what you want to search.
Lucia: 猜你想搜哈哈哈
Lucia: Guess what you want to search, hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈再来两个
Lucia: 哎好看哎
Lucia: 再来两个
Jake:要不不够了是吧
Tasha: 啊没关系还可以再切哈哈哈
Lucia: 没关系我来洗
Jake:哦哦哈哈哈
Lucia: 哎呦妈呀
Tasha: 哇直接变好看了哈哈
Jake:哇直接变好看了
Jake:挺好
Tasha: 真挺好
Lucia: 整挺好
Tasha: 还能再做什么奇怪的造型
Jake:还能再做什么奇怪的造型哈哈哈
Lucia: 没事不管是啥造型
Lucia: 咱都能给他整成跟那一样的
Jake:哎好的好那我再来一个
Tasha: 对对都会整好看的
Tasha: 您放心吧
Tasha: 那我再来一个
Tasha: Then I'll do another one.
Tasha: 好别做一样的
Tasha: Okay, don't make it the same.
Tasha: 发挥您的创造力
Tasha: Use your creativity.
Tasha: sorry是吧
Tasha: Sorry, right?
Jake:哦好吧OK
Jake: Oh, okay, got it.
Shure: 我这个宣布下线，线交还给你了不要再污蔑我了
Jake:哎好
Jake: Yeah, okay.
Jake:哈哈哈没污蔑
Tasha: 要干嘛好
Tasha: What do you want to do?
Jake:你要干嘛
Jake:你还要再加一下是吗
Jake: You want to add more, right?
Tasha: 你还要再加一下是吗
Tasha: You want to add more, right?
Jake:再加一个
Jake: Add one more.
Jake:好加一个
Jake: Okay, add one more.
Tasha: 好加一个
Tasha: Okay, add one more.
Jake:不不不加加右边
Jake: No, no, no, add it to the right.
Tasha: 就就这种不对称美感是吗
Tasha: So, this kind of asymmetrical beauty, right?
Jake:对对对好的好的
Jake: Yes, yes, exactly.
Tasha: 啊好的好的
Tasha: Ah, got it.
Tasha: 太会了
Tasha: You're really good at this.
Lucia: 给大家来一些草莓补给
Lucia: Bringing some strawberries for everyone.
Tasha: 我感觉就是很鲜明的能看出
Tasha: I feel like you can clearly see
Tasha: 这是两个人的风格
Tasha: the style of two different people.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 你知道吗
Tasha: You know?
Lucia: 哈哈哈啊哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake:我刚刚架了一堵墙
Jake: I just built a wall.
Lucia: 啊可以
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Jake:呃可以挺酷炫
Jake: Uh, it's pretty cool.
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 挺挺酷炫
Lucia: Pretty cool.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:然后干点啥呢
Jake: So, what should we do next?
Tasha: 呢
Tasha: Hmm?
Shure: 嗨 siri  siri你在哪
Shure: 我靠   不是你们  你们怎么这个样子对我的派呢
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake:炮台啊这是
Jake: Is this a cannon?
Tasha: 啊啊
Tasha: Ah, yeah.
Lucia: 为什么这个草莓变得越来越多
Lucia: Why are there more and more strawberries?
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈完了这个要弄4个哈
Jake: Hahaha, we need to make four of these, haha.
Lucia: 咱草莓不够啊
Lucia: We don't have enough strawberries.
Lucia: 哈哈有有有
Lucia: Haha, yes we do.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 已经没有了吧
Tasha: We're already out, right?
Lucia: 还有几个
Lucia: There are a few left.
Tasha: 哦我靠
Tasha: Oh my gosh.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Jake:这个可以弄一个
Jake: We can make one more.
Tasha: 好大呀换个小的
Tasha: It's too big, let's use a smaller one.
Jake:哈哈没关系你再把前面几个点哦OK OK
Jake: Haha, it's okay, just add some decoration to the previous ones. OK, OK.
Tasha: 没关系再把前面几个点缀点缀
Tasha: It's okay, just add some decoration to the previous ones.
Jake:后面每个都各有风格
Jake: Each one has its own style in the back.
Tasha: 后面每个都各有风格
Tasha: Each one has its own style in the back.
Lucia: 后面每个都各有风格对
Lucia: Each one has its own style, right.
Jake:对这个怎么办呢
Jake: Yes, what should we do with this one?
Tasha: 您随意吧
Tasha: Do whatever you want.
Jake:您随意吧好的
Jake: Do whatever you want, alright.
Jake:你你随意过头了
Jake: You, you went too far.
Tasha: 你已经随意过头了哈
Tasha: You already went too far, haha.
Lucia: 妮妮随意过头了
Lucia: Nini, you went too far.
Jake:弄个帘洞哈哈哈
Jake: Make a curtain cave, hahaha.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Huh?
Tasha: 哈梦幻联动
Tasha: Haha, a fantastic crossover.
Lucia: 双厨狂喜
Lucia: Double chef excitement.
Alice:这个是滋滋冒油版
Alice: This is the sizzling oil version.
Lucia: 不是这是可以录的吗
Lucia: Is this something we can record?
Jake:对不起对不起对不起
Jake: Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Lucia: 要不要记录一下时间
Lucia: Should we note the time?
Jake:哈哈哈确实不能说
Jake: Hahaha, we really can't say that.
Lucia: 就是那个
Lucia: It's just that...
Jake:呃马来西亚吉隆坡
Jake: Uh, Kuala Lumpur, Malaysia.
Tasha: 马来西亚吉隆坡
Tasha: Kuala Lumpur, Malaysia.
Jake:合合理了吧
Jake: Is that reasonable?
Tasha: 嗯这个好对
Tasha: Yes, this is good.
Lucia: 嗯特别合理
Lucia: Yes, very reasonable.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Tasha: 逐渐变稀
Tasha: It's getting thinner.
Lucia: 逐渐变稀是因为受热了吗对
Lucia: Is it getting thinner because of the heat? Right.
Tasha: 是因为树热了吗对
Tasha: Is it because of the heat from the tree? Right.
Tasha: 哎呀
Tasha: Oh no.
Tasha: OK
Tasha: OK.
Tasha: 翻出去吧
Tasha: Flip it over.
Jake:哈餐中甜点
Jake: Haha, dessert time.
Tasha: 啦啦
Tasha: La la.
Shure: 不是更近一点而是那个角度打光刚刚好
Tasha: 这是什么肉
Shure: 然后还有鸡翅鸡翅特香
Jake:哪了这个
Jake: Where is this?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Tasha: 你洗的筷子在哪
Jake:我洗的筷子在这
Jake: I washed the chopsticks here.
Jake:呃应该没用了
Jake: Uh, probably not useful anymore.
Tasha: 我没有问
Tasha: I didn't ask.
Jake:嗯那还有一个我也为谁了
Jake: Hmm, there's another one I washed too.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Tasha: 过
Tasha: Pass.
Lucia: much strong
Lucia: Much strong.
Lucia: 总感觉
Lucia: Always feels like...
Tasha: 我感觉脂肪看起来
Tasha: I feel like the fat looks...
Lucia: 这双看起来并不像没用过的样子
Lucia: These don't look unused.
Tasha: 并不像没用过的样子
Tasha: They don't look unused.
Lucia: 来冲一下吧
Lucia: Let's rinse them.
Tasha: 哦开吉他了
Tasha: Oh, got the guitar.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 嗯啊谢谢
Lucia: Hmm, thank you.
Lucia: 我说这双看起来并不像没用过的样子
Lucia: I said they don't look unused.
Jake:这双看起来并不像没用过的样子
Jake: They don't look unused.
Lucia: 我冲一下来着
Lucia: I'll rinse them.
Tasha: 火
Tasha: Fire.
Jake:哦呦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:哎好烫啊我靠
Jake: Oh, it's so hot.
Lucia: 呃不是您在干嘛
Lucia: Uh, what are you doing?
Tasha: 不火
Tasha: Not fire.
Jake:好烫啊
Jake: It's so hot.
Jake:好烫啊我靠
Jake: It's so hot, damn.
Lucia: 啊终于吃掉了
Lucia: Ah, finally ate it.
Alice:盘子有吗
Alice: Do we have plates?
Lucia: 这双啊谢谢
Lucia: These, thanks.
Lucia: 这双就先撂在这里面吧
Lucia: Let's just leave these here for now.
Lucia: 算了我也不想冲他了
Lucia: Never mind, I don't want to rinse them.
Jake:并不简单如呼吸
Jake: It's not as simple as breathing.
Alice:简单如呼吸
Alice: Simple as breathing.
Shure: 别录了别录了
Shure: 算呢不丢人了
Shure: 听过盘尼西林吗
Jake:听过
Shure: 真的码
Shure: 真的听过盘尼西林
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Okay.
Shure: 好 唱完你就带上了是吧
Tasha: 什么就带上了
Jake:来吃一个
Jake: Come, have a bite.
Jake:吃个什么呢我去
Jake: What should I eat, oh my.
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright.
Jake:好吃
Jake: Delicious.
Tasha: 吃到爆浆了吗还没有
Tasha: Did it burst with flavor yet? Not yet?
Tasha: 成为主厨哈哈
Tasha: Become the head chef, haha.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 怎么能什么都知道呢哈哈
Lucia: How can you know everything? Haha.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 你不喝的话
Tasha: If you don't drink...
Tasha: 我我认领你这杯酒可以吗好的
Tasha: I think you can have this drink, right?
Tasha: 那你能把杯子给我吗 空杯子
Tasha: 没事我去刷
Tasha: No worries, I'll wash it.
Tasha: 我要倒饮料啊
Tasha: I need to pour a drink.
Tasha: 那我刚好刷完给你倒了
Tasha: I'll pour it for you right after I finish washing.
Tasha: 我自己倒
Tasha: I'll pour it myself.
Tasha: 矿泉水
Tasha: Mineral water.
Shure: 要要不方便的话我挂了你查哈哈哈
Tasha: 吃到爆浆了吗
Tasha: Did it burst with flavor yet?
Tasha: 妈
Tasha: Mom.
Jake:吃到了但是感觉被奶油盖住了
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:就是奶油它 爆的比浆多
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Tasha: 我吃到了这个4号小蛋糕哈哈
Tasha: I ate this number 4 small cake, haha.
Tasha: 这谁的筷子
Tasha: Whose chopsticks are these?
Tasha: 都在这里面 如果没有 可能就无了
Tasha: 哇今天走了1万步全都被自己吃掉了
Tasha: Wow, I walked 10,000 steps today and ate it all back.
Tasha: 嗯回来直接睡了一觉
Tasha: Hmm, I came back and took a nap right away.
Tasha: 这个时候就应该开始弯腰摔死我
Tasha: At this moment, I should start bending over and die from the fall.
Tasha: 摇骰子谁输了谁玩
Tasha: Roll the dice, whoever loses, plays.
Tasha: 手机上
Tasha: On the phone.
Tasha: 吃的好认真
Tasha: Eating so seriously.
Tasha: 太好吃了
Tasha: It's too delicious.
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Tasha: 明天
Tasha: Tomorrow.
Tasha: 因为感觉没人吃了
Tasha: Because it feels like no one is eating it.
Tasha: 这个好喝吗
Tasha: Is this tasty?
Tasha: 啊这还有你的呢
Tasha: Ah, this one is yours too.
Tasha: 都
Tasha: All
Tasha: 都是你的
Tasha: All of it is yours.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 现在不喝就忌口
Tasha: If you don't drink it now, you'll miss out.
Tasha: 不知道瞎吃
Tasha: Don't just eat randomly.